perhaps you're receiving is weakness
[Music]
so find the television
cheers
like if you had a towel and it was full
of water and you was ringing out I
wonder was
foreign
[Music]
when you've got a strip of stable hips
and you've got a little Quick Squeeze
you are sure spiritually you put that
into many things that you do with uh
with the cane and jug yeah
[Music]
but you make it into like a ball of
energy
[Music]
so when I'm here I'm listening to the
the sounds
[Music]
um
listen Association
so they're all different sounds
when you can make it something with a
like a little
explosion
now it's not been this machine yet
intense as well as
as well as good form it's becoming then
very intense uh
when he first try okay now we're done
because you've gone back to
concentrating on wanting to hit it
strong my numbers
[Music]
are strong it's the tabernuchi that's
built it up
and then you basically
you should